well we will always remember Aretha
Franklin as the Queen of Soul legendary
Motown musician that Smokey Robinson
will remember her as his oldest friend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
baby baby Robinson and Franklin
performed together several times
throughout the decade but they met long
before they were stars growing up in the
same neighborhood in Detroit Smokey
Robinson joins us now from Glendale
California Smokey Robinson it is good to
see you
gale my love it's good to see you too
how are you doing I'm all right I'm all
right of course we're all thinking about
Aretha but that was some neighborhood
you guys grew up in you had Diana Ross
The Supremes that's in tations The Four
Tops Berry Gordy was there how did you
two become friends and what was it like
to see her become your childhood friend
become the Queen of Soul well we became
friends because the she and her family
moved to Detroit when I was 8 years old
really and you know kids are her brother
Cecil who was my lifelong ace boon [ __ ]
till he passed you know came around to
just play with the guys in the
neighborhood and we went around to see
his new house and in Detroit we lived in
the hood in the hood hood oh okay but in
the middle of that were these two plush
blocks where they had mansions and all
that right in the middle it was an
amazing place and so they lived on one
of those blocks because a reference II
or Franklin was of course one of the
biggest ministers in the country and so
we went around to see their new house
which was a mansion we're walking
through the house to see and I hear this
little voice and a piano playing
somewhere in his room and this voice
come in and and and I peek in and
there's a wreath is sitting at the piano
playing and singing almost like she did
as an adult and she proves probably only
about five years old
but that's our first met her yeah and
what was it like performing with her
side-by-side smoky you guys did that
many times well you know it was always
it was always wonderful to do anything
with the retailer either was like I said
my ace you know she was a baby and um
and so
we were really really close and to do
anything with her was always a joy snow
can you talk a little bit about the the
the cultural moment that both you and
she embodied in America at a time where
African Americans were where it was a
very tough part of American history she
was a cultural icon and was at the
center of a cultural change well yeah I
would say that we all grew up in that
era we grew up in the in the Rosa Parks
era I call it because she was the start
of it all and we marched with dr. Martin
Luther King and Reverend Ralph Abernathy
we did the sit-ins we did all the stuff
that was required of us at that time we
turned the other cheek which was really
really really hard to do sometimes under
the circumstances but that's what we had
to do because that was the plan and it
was a master plan and as you can see it
worked pretty well yeah and we know
there obviously was only one Aretha she
isn't a league of her own and can't be
replaced but who are some of the younger
generation singers that that she really
respected and thought had a future as
leaders in the music industry
well Aretha was like me Gail a reason
loved music and she loved new artists
and and when I see people talking about
today well you know the music business
is in trouble because all the new
artists are there so there that you know
there are some wonderful new artists out
there show businesses that has a great
future according to what's happening out
there with new artists and a reason
appreciated that and I don't know who
she specifically would have said oh this
is my favorite new artist but she
appreciated the fact that there were new
artists out there you know her
granddaughter is a great thing my
granddaughter you know so it's a you
know it just goes on and on well you
know we've certainly lost a legend what
do you think that the music world has
lost with with the death of Aretha
Franklin in terms of what she meant to
us musically just her presence I mean
you know because I talked to Aretha
about maybe five weeks ago or so and her
plan was she was going to retire from
doing performances
but she was all always going to record
she said smoke I'm just not gonna do any
more dates but I'm gonna continue to
record but she has left us with a
musical musical legacy that kids who
haven't even been born yet
will get a chance to experience that is
so true now I hear a music differently
smoking knowing that we can't hear it
live again I hear different things that
I hadn't heard before listening to her
voice and seeing the together it's pure
magic smokey I'm sure a lot of viewers
are out there googling your
granddaughter hers as well right now as
I speak yeah thank you so much for
joining us